[Music]
in parenting hack news you bring the
grandparents in yes that's the one that
sucks for me or you abandon your
children think big brain time big thank
you to submitted by baby proof a mom
shares the perfect hack hack to stop her
kids from begging for toys in stores
don't even buy it in the first don't
know all the stores don't don't take
them don't go outside
leave them at daycare cover the toy and
poop real quick blindfold there you go
how do you do this smack them cuz even
even Tiger at this age no matter where
we go you'll see a toy and he's like
immediately obsessed with it so my trick
right now is like like I went to home
goods he'll play ball
did you realize basketball so I'm all
cool so I'll bring him the basketball so
the whole time he's in the car he's
playing and then we get when we get to
the checkout then my goal Papa's gonna
pay for it he goes ok and I'm a kid yeah
they don't need to know everything
Phoebe I remember one time he got me
cards I didn't have something my hand
airplane hey gene babe do that one I'll
tell my bottom Jesus that's the one I
tell them I'll buy it for him when he
can [ __ ] say it clearly that's why
you need to just keep the cats but I
cants perfectly fit your personality
he'll never be able to pronounce it
alright so Kristina
Christina oh she's so happy yeah so she
posted this on her Facebook that's a lot
of writing to what I see a caption that
long I just like I check out there's
nothing that that's long listen I will
read it for you have my assistant read
it once I guess oh right
she writes once again my camera roll is
full of pictures of Emerson with every
single thing she wants for Christmas why
because it's the most amazing parenting
heck ever and has stopped many meltdowns
if you are using this heck listen up
friends our trips to the store used to
be a lot more painful this time of year
toys are out in full force and of course
my kids want it all obviously I would
love to have sweets well mannered non
greedy chill kids that don't ask for all
the things but I don't so drop your
judgement Karen and stops stop reading
if you have kids like that now if you
want to have if you have kids like mine
that want the shiny amazing things that
fill target the grocery store office
Depot the gas station pretty much
everywhere you go this time of year and
this is for you
what is it take a picture it's that
simple
pause for a second comment on the thing
they're pointing out and say let's take
a picture with it and send it to Santa
so he knows you want it nope you can
send it to Santa grandma or whoever you
can pawn this off on totally up to you
but it can be different every time
magically any smile says cheese ask to
see the picture and then put the toy
down and walks away it's magical no
tears no tantrums by either of us and
she forgets all about them within
minutes maybe you've been doing this for
ages and you selfishly didn't share this
tip with me or maybe you're like me and
this is about to rock your world for
real try it friends you're welcome
which is kind of something that you're
doing long it's then what you'd like you
give them the satisfaction of the
validity of like oh you'd acknowledge
that I want this dad or whatever yeah
and then but then you'll forget about it
but what about when they are older and
they can remember longer cuz I hold
resentment when you you said you were
gonna buy me the pirate ship but you
still didn't mother
that's what you
in this cause like Santa Santa just you
know can't get you every [ __ ] thing
that you pick out so like this is our
daughter and so she takes photos with
everything that she was literally has
like over two hundred five don't the kid
read his article Jesus okay carry on
yeah oh there you go never teach to get
greed exactly then you'll be ahead of
the curve every time you just be like
all it says here you can't have this
mark when do you break when when so tech
is holding a basketball I never break
Jill breaks all the time really why
could you like shut up already I'll buy
it no I'll just try to figure out
different ways but I think like since my
time with Tigers shorter I could add
more patience during that period of time
whereas Jays probably trying to do all
these errands and all these things and
go to a supermarket so like sometimes
she comes home with tyka and this fool
has like a fifth soccer ball why is
there she goes that's the truth about
parents sometimes you just the kid just
they have too much energy this is like I
know it was probably bit terrible but
just shut up I watched this Kevin Hart
stand up dingy and he was talking about
how when he comes home and then when you
have like that between two to four year
old sometimes you've come over a long
day of work and the minute you open your
door and that guy's like daddy you just
want to get right back in the car
I felt that for the first time when I
came home and as I was walking up to the
doorstep I could already hear Tiger
screaming so I don't even see his face
I'm just like already four red bulls
[Music]
yeah energy like 100 my son my youngest
one he still cares about me he's like
you wanna play Mario with me and I'm
just like how is it 11 when do they stop
cared about my my oldest cared about
stopped around 11 days away yeah dear
days away
yeah so that's why I play with him for
like a few moments I'm just like we need
to stop caring but not your own time I
don't think I want to play fifa by
myself in my video games just not with
you but you're not [ __ ] kuzey he
wants to play Mario can you imagine
you're in the eighteen hundred's and
your son's like dad let's play and then
you look at his [ __ ] stick in the
monitor I gotta make a swear jar I was
like the plague holy [ __ ]
I pictured different like you're
probably gonna ride horses and go
hunting and [ __ ] or something dope you
know yeah just trying to stay about
dying Calero with me daddy
I would tow kids up that's just boring
like straight up like when they tell me
to play with stuff and I'll pretend to
play with it
this is [ __ ] boring let's do some fun
[ __ ] cuz I go in like I really enjoy the
[ __ ] if we're starting to play puzzles
like I'm in it like I'm not playing with
the kid anymore
let me show you how to do alright yeah
that's actually we yeah you get in right
you're just ugh you want to buy this toy
cuz you want to play with it yes it's
always way [ __ ] better there's a good
reason for having kids
yeah no judgement of buying toys and
kids movies and Uncrustables sandwiches
they're so [ __ ] good
yeah yeah yeah my kids have soccer games
and they're handing out snacks no you
know it's funny so this year I've been
asking eyes because it's Christmas and
then his birthday in January something
back back so much cuz then you got a bar
gives back or you do it my parent my
parents parents did they just get the
one good life sucks for you that's a
good lesson for kids life isn't fair
don't you want to deprive them of joy so
when they earn that [ __ ] in the future
they can enjoy it that much more yes
it's like prologue like trying to get
them from watching porn not because it's
like mad or whatever like but in their
teen years or whatever you're like hey
you don't want your date to go numb and
you don't want to you don't want to you
don't want to back in you don't want to
look at a [ __ ] tentacle porn when
you're 20 years old wanna [ __ ] up
octopus 121 he's like in all those nuts
when you get hard at a seafood
restaurant tartar sauce
[Laughter]
Joe said oh yeah that'd be her way over
the line
Joe's like this is too much this is why
though what he's saying is why I feel
like rich kids always tend to do drugs
because I knew growing up did drugs cuz
I get over [ __ ] stimulated checking on
kids at Nobu he does he only wants one
thing though and that's the one thing
I'm not gonna get okay this is a
Christmas and birthday trying to get him
to hang on one more goddamn year wait
does he not have a phone it's a wash he
don't ever call it alright now here's a
wash
oh so you're not getting hit a phone and
not getting him back the next year
you're gonna give him up not going to
listen okay it's at least another year
of me not having to deal with some
[ __ ]
I love having my kids having phone
what's the difference they're funny my
iPad at home so he does my got his dad's
he has an iPad so he'll be watching
YouTube and stuff like so he does have
access but the personality was having
this if your number that's where you're
like that that's around like hold on
you're just one more you just give me
one more year and it's because there's
like a whole bunch of like this one more
year for you to prepare yourself well
it's that plus they're saying like
statistically and there's a lot of
campaigns going on like at school and
stuff that they're just like wait till
eight eight like eighth grade or
something so it's just like you know
there's a correlation with depression
and like psychological problems with
young age and cell phone usage yeah so
like the younger like the more problems
you'll have psychologically so I'm just
saying just I've always had something
though even though when we were kids
they'd have cell phones like the kids
had game boys yeah it was always
something to have the way that a lot of
the apps are designed is to release a
lot of dopamine so it's almost like
smoking cigarettes or something where
it's you know kind of clinically proven
to be like a drug where they're dose
their head with about TV video games you
get dopamine from team I'm always like
worried did we are we really doing more
because I don't feel like i doing well I
take that back because I already had to
be outside when I was a kid too but
that's also because you yeah I've seen
sign so for me it's like but like for me
it's like taking it one step further by
like having the like the access to like
social media and stuff like having
things where it's like he's just not
ready yet like you don't need to get
there you is he not ready or are you not
ready
he's already I loved having kids have
phones i text them and post mates it's
war water for dinner group orders put
your thing in it's like this is the boss
I believe you are you okay with the kid
having a phone I wanted him earlier hey
God my wife was my wife was liked if she
was literally the same way I'm like ah
man I want to text them no no selfish
because I was always out of town I want
to text and belay me what's up I don't
want to Skype with them yeah but he had
my youngest had when they like um eight
but he could never take it out of the
house school he could just like watching
YouTube in iPad he gets to iMessage his
friends okay so you got him on like baby
yeah which is fine
I'm jealousy you okay because my family
is bad at gifs really you get a group
chat with my son he'll if I mention I
mean he's like I'm like he's all the new
gifs that just come out all right fella
tones you I have one brother who does
gifs all well and then another one I'm
like you should just stop
[Music]